über die do
was ja mir doch egal ja
das die Diskussion sprü Ken a
Vegetarierin in und
auswendig ke Fleisch
[Applaus]
mehr Schlachter erwach W
mir bin Exo a
Vegetarierin
ja 27 Jahr später ist die vegetarische
ernah verbreitet und
akzeptiert der Urban gagende aber wie
der W ichach B auf dem Land bin ich hier
immer noch dir mit der extra wünsch
was mit vegetaris Menü Fleisch nee das
geht nicht geht das nicht 8% Fleisch
essen muss den Fleisch mus mus Konsument
verbi
[Musik]
Fleisch da
obter Zimmer da bin ich
aufgeachsen und hier wie wie mus l
brzere es ist früh die morgen he wird
ichuche
schkollegere drit
Generation
vegetarierinzerei bin
überhauptkommen
geh ja wie geht
dir die
morgen
sicheret
[Musik]
das
bring
g es ist wie früh auf dem schuhwg die
sä du machst komischer
Kopf
wieso aber sch so wei das schon mal
merkt es geh g zu d mir es ist schon so
eine Sache ich den
das sich das stressfi geht
und
machen die vom
schlachtle
Kindheit
Nachricht
ja
[Musik]
ich hab mir wie nicht dr GEW es
ja rech Schlag man muss ja die
B fr
verst
vegetaris aber ich natürlich l die B mal
sag got ist das muss das so ist das
so Verständnis für die vegetarische
wachst aber
m nsten
Umfeld Grund l nicht zu letzte vi
Jahr ist es mehr oder zum Thema worden
also nicht vegetarisch sie aber
sie nicht gessen sie he g
[Musik]
sie
kulturchock irgendwie da dämpft die
Tomate
[Musik]
mitt ja
okay ke Problem aber
dasp das ein mitag ist ja
hierter noch muss ich nicht das ist mit
da Fleisch das ist sch aber nach
ich
Woch m
schulkollegis verändert L mit
Fleischkonsum der Schwizer geh hier
langsam veränderig schwizerin und
Schwizer
weniger Fleisch a noch vor 30 Jahr Prof
S 50 kg pro Jahr das ist Hal
gichtig Vegetarierin
5% jed 20 Schwizer ist das
Fleisch Generation V natürlich
sowieso sich sch das
ist
[Musik]
st
sich
[Musik]
Produkt
hambur
schon natürlich schon
irgend
schon
sortimentig vi offen
[Musik]
vegetarierinen
Z auf Grill
ja
zum
Z das
ist Jahre ist sicher fest im
Sortiment im
Sommer
warumtim aber
einfachund komm
grillfestft ist einfach
MW über
meistensisch
ist f
Produkt der letzte 5 Jahre sch das Best
großverteil MRO viel Innovation im Gang
Nachfrag nach den Produkt Land nach wie
vorurban G
aber
[Musik]
dasmer Exem
aber
Jay
tchüss der
Wind wie mus fertigge sondern ja
wie recht fertig aber so ze sie
Verständnis das ist jetzt viel meh a
früer mit Vegetarierin S auf Land wenn
mit der Familie ab
und bin
ich im Negativ
sin und
hier
klassische
hier bin ich se 15
jah Land bin ich g dir mit dem extra
Wunsch ich bin
Nerv
und
wenn so gut wie möglich
das gut es
geht vegetaris aber meist ist das
eigentlich wenn irgendwie gro 8 wir und
S no gro vi stätische Region oder so
wo W vielle ger vegetarisch
z. derer macht gerade Menü Vorschlag was
ist zum mit der mit dem vegetarischen
Menü und Suppe ist Fleischs nee das geht
nicht geht das nicht
ne drin drin nicht vi kocht worden da
wi z.B so neue Ideen hat
bez oder so ne B nicht also ich muss
sag
pensioniert
W
aber intere natürlich so groß das ist
die junge die
junge
das ma natürlich
einfach das
vegetarischürlich ganz klar
vegetarisch
aberke da muss
manum
ein füht sichis
unverstange
Gruppe stand
das vegetarische
Kasse
ja nicht sag sehr frundlich
s let sie na
natürlich nach erklärt
dass
broschü
clubend
und irg
veg Restaurant oder
Hotel Kurs machen über
vegetar und
das
vor die me
Vegetarier
Stör Präsenz v
themais
aber V Fleisch
geh ja das ist
natürlich
natürlich mit
Konf
normal ja gen
mum so ja terass
zurü Mittag natür
nicht mit
dem
be
jeder Nachfrag entsprechend groß wie ist
das H vielle so ist man da weniger sage
verschloss ist mir da
toleranter einfach meh also das ist kom
her vor da wir manmer so wie vor 15
Jahr sondern ja ist einfach okay ist
probiert beste ma
mit was anstatt mit
jateade
nicht ab und
zu auf
Kar
aberw ST D man offener mus D Vegetarier
in so z und D man auch tolerant und und
flexib VI
mal machen
vgebot sicher immer noch sehr begrenzt
und was merke vi
so wirklich
neuesprierenü V gü
nicht Familie pun lang nicht
Fleisch doch ung und schad so war die
nicht groß und stark
sopr Mittagstisch vonus ihr Familie
sowiesolich
Familie sprü gehört ich zurück
zu
fürof derwirtschaft und
Fleischproduktion
zwunger immer noch Vegetarierin denkt
wie
den Schwingfest sag
mal
Schwingfest ja mir doch
egal und do schön WN die BR Schwiz
produzierenland
spber sch
lang garantier dass
[Gelächter]
B
mit der SPR ist der H
ganz nicht verändert mir macht immer
wenn ich Schluss ein zumz
[Musik]
mü V den da weles Brun da da liegt J
limusinstraße das
ist nach vor vom Betrieb
nachm gro kommt aus Fleisch kann man so
sagen ja
ne das ke
bring also geh wie
Pirat Situation Pirat
V und das ist vielleicht der groß unched
W
wird W zum vermchl also es ist nach wie
vor ja Respekt du dprechend behandel
aber da
eigentlich Problem ma falsch Job das ist
sich nicht
einfachich das gehört da zuu das ich
mache das
und
KT mit das LFT mir noch ke Stress
und macht
einfach
fertig mit der
H zu
geh das da da das ist v der
Lieblings
ja
Nerv genau
das Nerv
langsam W
wio
vegetarisch der H ja sogarerland
produziert
nicht der AAU nicht ohne nee das ist
nicht das ist
derw was da ausbucht Option hier n
vegetarische lebensmitt
produzieren
ja get was
im Option das kann ich machen
aber kann ich
vergessenb das
geh wieso ja
Flag die FL das geht
wenig
dass im Moment nicht der Bund die
Zukunft die
Pflanz Z Klimastrategie
2050 Pflanz produzi und weniger
Fleisch gut wenigis
was find h
zu
drübert% Fleisch mus Fleisch mus
Konsument verbi
FIS wirklich schriftlich
Verb glau
vegetar
akzeptiert Verst Frage jetzt Ichis
Vegetarier ja h ich nicht ja aber der
war V Vegetarier was erwart ich du vom
vegetar akzeptiert
Fleischesser die Kommentare
vonz na sag
Mörder tierschander da geht x
Ausdrück das tut mir weh g nicht mit dem
es Block mich ganz ehrlich W einfach
denke wie
Teil nicht kennt und das tut mir
wirklich
schlimm glü
[Musik]
wie schaffet wie mit der TI UMG da füt
Unverstand gich
kritisiert
Gesellschaft zum
mich sehr irtiert ja wir wie z
berührigspunkt mit der mit der
burerei mit der vielle mit der L wo
Fleisch
[Musik]
produzieren was dankst du über das Thema
Schre Kommentar und ich freue mich auf
Diskussion
mehrf Kanal abonnieren und ja dron
empfäig für eine Film V SRF impact der
geht zum Nachhaltigkeit von
fleischersatzprodukt